bonsoir madame voudront bien de 24,60
bonsoir depuis que vous avez appris la
mort de votre fils il ya un an déjà
vous l'avez eu cesse d'entreprendre des
actions de lancer des appels à l'aide
pour que l'on prévienne kedro que
d'autres des murs tombent au combat en
fait
et là vous lancez extreme dialogue un
dialogue extrême quel est le message que
vous voulez envoyer ses programmes
d'éducation pour les enfants pour les
jeunes pour savoir qu'est ce qui se
passe avec les familles les émotions
qu'est ce qui arrive quand ce qu'on
engage avec du monde comme ça et puis
c'est manière qu'on vous savoir en
avance pour prévenir que yann offert des
décisions pour joindre avec des groupes
comme ça votre histoire
quelle est elle racontez là nous le sel
de damon sa conversion vers l'islam et
au fond vous la verriez vous venir mais
il va a converti en 2008 et c'était bon
commencement et puis en 2011 a commencé
à changer
je peux avoir des changements avec ses 1
avec lui la doller son coeur on peuvent
avoir quelque chose qui va l'en mais en
même temps on sert à rien de ça vaut
coopérer n'a rien de ça et puis en 2012
novembre 2012
il a pris pour il m'a dit egypte mais
j'ai trouvé après en janvier que s'ils
étaient partis pour céder et puis point
alors est alors tout seul et je t'assure
téléphone avec lui tout temps tous les
jours tous les deux ou trois jours
jusqu'à juin 2013
et puis s'arrêter ce temps là au
commencement il était avec ja bataille
où ça il va changer en juin et états
avec un état islamique
et puis il m'a va contacter une autre
fois sur facebook n'avait envoyé des
messages stala il va complètement
changer
c'était pas mon petit garçon après ça et
puis après ça j'ai tant de lui incertain
et ça va arrêter tout de suite et puis
j'ai attendu en janvier 2014 et à tuer
fait serrer la main qu'est ce que
voulait dire par je ne reconnaissais pas
mon fils quel discours vous tenez t-il
qu'est-ce qu'il vous dise
donc forcément il parle à twitter qui
manque en tout le monde la famille et
ils m'ont encore tout ce qui la vache et
nous avec nous la famille et après du
temps est pas là seulement 2 à rien de
trop et 10 la patrouille thèmes
distincts vraiment analystes à dix
connectés de tout le monde ça me semble
que est à fois phlébite
c'est changer comme ça c'est à pas lui
c'est à lui avec sa voix puis c'est tout
ça pour lui la da est ce que vous
parlait de faire le djihad de tuer les
mécréants de de la haine de l'occident
il pas la jama de tout ça est pas là
seulement que jaka là il mangea bon pied
il y avait des amis de partout de monde
et c'est tout quitter à tout temps on
dit beaucoup que les jeunes recherchent
une manière de donner un sens à leur vie
qu'est ce qui manquait à des miennes ici
pour être un jeune homme heureux
il voit là et engager je crois à faire
quelque chose meilleur que seulement un
petit job
il voulait faire quelque chose plus gros
il va là est plus au centre de quelque
chose qui t'a avec du mini la
signification ou et passionnant était
vraiment passionnant et voilà trouver
quelque chose là et je crois que c'est à
ça ils volent à aider les femmes voilà
aider les enfants
alors comment expliquez-vous ce
revirement
je peux pas l'expliquer croyez-vous
qu'il a été
victime de l'internet ou d'autres
personnes qu'il fréquentait à calgary
oui je crois que c'est combinations de
toute neuve à quelqu'un ici mais aussi
sur médias sociaux et l'internet et des
sites web n'a pas beaucoup d'arts
martiaux l'eau et je crois que c'est les
deux ensemble pascal amende de 2000 vous
avez appris qu'il était sous la
surveillance des services de
renseignement depuis près de deux ans
oui dans saviez rien rien du tout elle y
invite aux parents j'ai envie de me
thérèse considérons qu'on aurait dû vous
informer même s'il était adulte de ce
projet benjamin il savoir pour faire
l'intervention avec la famille ou
quelque chose pour trouver là y est pour
arrêter tout ça mais j'ai jamais reçu
nous avons regardé avec le recul est-ce
que vous avez une idée de ce qui aurait
pu empêcher des mieux de partir en syrie
je ne sais pas mais en même temps je
voyais jamais vu la chance pour essayer
pour le convaincre d'aller et pour
comprendre qu'est ce qui se passe avec
tout ça et j'ai jamais eu la chance
jamais mais parce que on semble dire que
beaucoup de jeunes se préparent dans le
plus grand secret ne laisse pas
entrevoir leurs projets ou et puis c'est
salir mais en même temps comme des
parents nous pour dire nous pouvons dire
que dans quelque chose de mal
on peut voir là quelque chose qui change
avec nos jeunes et avec ça avec
l'éducation et le savoir que ce
spectacle iris pression pour aller en
série vous avec ça on pourra trouver
quelqu'un d'autre pour nous aider pour
faire des interventions qu'il est le
meilleur moyen d'après vous pour
prévenir la radicalisation
je crois que ça va prend beaucoup
d'action ça va prendre d'éducation ça va
prendre les communautés qui vomit
ensemble pour trouver les os pour se
porter tous les familles
les jeunes en avance quand ce qu'ils
sont vraiment j'ai donc on trouvait
façon pour connecter avec les jeunes et
c'est ça que ça fait maintenant avec
extreme dialogue on va commencer avec ça
a payé
on retrouve et d autres façons pour
trouver des élections dans les
communautés bouturer avec des jeunes
mais le projet de recherche qui
financent extrême dialogue va se
terminer là bientôt il y aura plus de
financement que nous voulons c'est de ça
je ne sais pas encore font autour
d'auteurs réseau et je veux continuer de
chercher d'autres ressources pour
continuer tous les actions que je peux
maintenant pourquoi on fait tout ça car
je vais faire ce que personne d'autre
allez travers tout ça c'est toujours
difficile safar aux chromes vraiment mal
dans mon coeur tous les jours
aujourd'hui ce que vous recevez une aide
quelconque mais gouvernement un soutien
quelconque n'ont même pas des deux
psychologique rire du tout pas idiot non
madame boudreau merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous aujourd'hui
là c'est merci bon courage là c'est trop
court merci